Good.
Okay.
So as you remember before we ended,
we were talking about Xoxo and how he explained everything in more detail than
people wanted to hear about.
Okay.
And he knew exactly the story that you had chairs of cyclohexane and you had
boat and you could enter,
convert them by rotation about single bonds.
But it was only after the Bragg's had determined the x ray structure of diamond
and more,
not equally importantly,
but very importantly had drawn clear pictures of it like this,
that people understood what Zazi had been talking about,
uh,
28 years earlier.
Okay.
Because if we look in the middle there,
we see that chair form of cyclohexane okay.
That we call it a chair that people like to give sort of silly trivial names to
things.
Scientists are probably sort of geeks actually.
But uh,
that's okay.
So there's a chair,
right?
That looks like this chair and that chair has a particular property which is you
can fold the back down and fold the legs up.
Hey,
but you can do the same thing to do the ring flip as we call it.
Then the chair cyclohexane by counter rotation of two parallel bonds.
So take these two bonds there,
rotate it that way,
and there rotate that way.
Counter rotation,
right?
One rotates clockwise,
the other counter clockwise and you rotate group four at the bottom right?
So that it goes up.
Everybody see how the rotation does that?
And I can do it with a model here,
right?
So I rotate it around,
this bond and this bond hold this part here and I rotate and it goes up.
Okay.
Now,
so the product after rotating that up is a different confirmation,
uh,
which we call boat cyclohexane or which people called boat cyclohexane because
it looks a little like a boat.
Okay.
And people who got very imaginative named various bonds on this,
like the bow spirit or the flag pole.
But in fact,
this isn't really a con formation at all because it's not a minimum of energy.
It's a maximum of energy.
You get lower energy,
this is the boat.
You get lower energy by twisting a little bit like that,
right?
So the boat is actually not a minimum of energy.
Usually we reserve the name Khan formation,
four isomers that are Minima in energy,
right?
They can vibrate,
but they're at a minimum of energy.
That's not true of the boat.
But the boat is what does oxy made his picture of it and it's easy to think
about.
So we often talk about the boat even if it isn't true,
if it really wants to twist a little bit,
we'll discuss that a little bit more later.
Why it wants to twist.
But anyhow,
there's a boat.
Now if you then did the same trick to the blue bonds on the other side,
that is a counter rotate.
So those go in and down rather than in and up as the,
as the red ones did on the left,
it goes down like that.
And now you see what you have is a chair where everything that was up is down
and everything that was down is up.
Okay?
So we started with a,
with a boat here,
I can flip it like that to make a capsized boat or a chair.
Start with a chair,
flip it to make a capsized boat.
Flip it again.
And I have another chair.
But notice what happened here.
All the,
all these bonds that are pointing vertical or down in vertical,
uh,
are black.
And the others are our silver,
right?
Everybody see that?
But after I do this,
they've changed the silver ones point up and down in the black ones.
Point out,
right?
So that's changed the environment that's interchange the environment of this one
and this one of the black and the,
and the,
the metal one,
right?
By doing that so-called ring flip.
Okay?
Now you,
you should learn how to draw chairs.
Cyclo hexanes that's a very popular discipline among organic chemists.
And it shows that you understand what's going on with the confirmation if you
draw it right.
And if you don't draw it right,
it shows that you don't understand.
So let's see how people say,
Oh,
I'm not an artist.
I can't really draw it right?
But if you understand that you can draw it right?
All the only thing you have to be capable of doing is drawing things that are
parallel to one another.
That's not too big a challenge.
Okay?
So notice that there,
that the carbon carbon bonds are parallel in pairs,
right?
So the redwoods are parallel,
the blue ones are parallel,
and the green ones are parallel,
okay?
Now that means when you draw the frame,
it looks like this.
So that opposite ones are parallel to one another.
And now the only challenge is to put the hydrogens on or whatever the
substituents are,
right?
And for that purpose,
it's worth knowing that,
noticing the symmetry of the ring,
right?
There are,
there's a threefold axis of symmetry vertical as a drawn it here,
right?
So you can rotate 120 degrees,
a third of a circle around that axis,
and you can't tell that it happened.
It's symmetry.
Okay?
So notice that the,
some of the bonds are parallel.
They're called axial because they're parallel at,
but some of them are parallel up and the intervening ones are parallel down to
keep the carbons looking tetrahedral.
Okay,
so six of the hydrogen bonds are parallel to the axis of symmetry.
So even if you drew the,
the six membered ring in some cockeyed direction so that it's playing mean plane
was like this or like this or like this or like this.
Still you can see where that access points and make the axial bonds parallel to
that access.
Okay.
Now you have the problem of drawing the,
the last bond which completes the tetrahedron.
Now over notice that the equatorial bonds is,
they're called,
cause it's sorta like the equator relative to the access.
They're not strictly horizontal,
right?
They go a little bit opposite the way the red bond went on the same carbon.
And notice in particular that they're parallel to the next adjacent carbon
carbon bonds,
which are shown in blue here.
Okay?
So they make us sort of an n or a z with the next adjacent carbon carbon bond.
Now what a clock is,
if we start from that carbon at the back left,
what direction started from the carbon?
Do I draw a line to draw the proper orientation of the hydrogen at that carbon?
You know,
one o'clock,
two o'clock,
three o'clock,
eight o'clock,
seven o'clock,
nine o'clock what?
Oh clock.
Think about it the second and then I'll ask you,
oh,
we can do it like an auction.
I'll go one,
two,
three,
four,
five and you raise your hand when I get the right one.
Okay.
12 o'clock.
One o'clock.
Two o'clock.
Three o'clock.
Four o'clock.
Five o'clock,
six o'clock,
seven o'clock eight o'clock nine o'clock 10 o'clock 11 o'clock.
Okay.
The answer is eight o'clock right?
Well how do I know that?
Because it's parallel to the next adjacent cc bond there.
Right.
See The z.
So it's parallel to the next adjacent z.
The CC bond.
Okay.
Now,
how about there?
One o'clock.
One o'clock,
two o'clock,
three o'clock,
four o'clock,
five o'clock day.
It's about one 30 right?
Sorta like one o'clock because it's parallel to the next adjacent cc bonds,
which are pointing that anti parallel,
right?
That parallel,
but in the opposite direction from their nearest carbon.
Okay.
Try here.
One o'clock,
two o'clock,
three o'clock,
four o'clock,
five o'clock.
Ah,
you're getting better,
right?
About four o'clock.
Three 30 maybe.
Okay.
How about here?
One o'clock,
two o'clock.
Three o'clock.
Okay.
Two o'clock.
Hey,
how bout here?
One,
two,
three.
Ah,
I've got some votes for one.
Now I'm going to come back and ask wrong with one o'clock bay there is what it
is.
It's actually seven o'clock.
How is that related to one o'clock?
It's anti parallel,
right?
If you did one o'clock,
it would have made a you with the next adjacent bond rather than an n or a z.
You see that?
See where the mistake was.
Okay?
So if you understand this,
if you understand that the hydrogen is Auntie to the next adjacent cc bond,
right,
then you won't draw it wrong.
You won't draw you,
which would be eclipsed,
right?
You'd draw it Auntie,
which is makes a z or an N.
Okay?
So if you,
if you understand that,
you'll draw it.
So it wouldn't be surprising if that were on some tests,
some time to draw a cyclohexane or something.
Okay.
Now this got interesting because in the 1940s and 50s,
synthetic organic chemist,
we're very interested in steroid hormones in the 30s,
forties and fifties right?
Uh,
and it turned out that you had these two alcohols,
which were called Beta and alpha.
And Beta is the one that came up toward the viewer.
And Alpha is the one that goes back into the paper.
But of course that depends on how you drew the molecule.
If you do the molecule upside down,
it'd be just the opposite.
But synthetic,
organic chemists who are interested in this kind of thing,
we weren't bothered like that about this because they always drew it the same
way,
right?
So they knew what they meant by up and down.
But that's like,
uh,
you know,
names that don't really tell you what the,
don't allow a novice to know what the structure is to call,
Talk Alpha and Beta people still talk about Alpha and Beta substituents,
the ones that point out of the paper and into the paper and steroids.
But you have to know the Lord.
You have to be,
you have to know how people always draw the rings in order to know what comes
out and what comes in.
So,
uh,
so it's like CIS and Trans a little bit not knowing what sister,
what hae a buyer remember said it didn't make a difference because,
because there was only one cyclohexane carboxylic acid,
right?
Because if you had axial and equatorial ones,
they see the rings could flip it,
they would enter converted it all be the same.
Right?
Uh,
so,
but it's interesting that the Beta and the Alpha isomers of these alcohols have
different reactivity.
They are different,
right?
They behave differently.
They don't enter,
convert.
Right.
And you can see why that would be.
So what's the relation between the Beta and the Alpha?
Are they mirror images?
Are they eating?
Are there environments?
Identical?
Ian Antia topic Diastat area topic.
There's an easy way to recognize this.
This is,
they exist at a chiral center because going around one carbon and going around
the other are different paths.
They encounter different things as you move along,
right?
So it's a chiral center,
but there are other chiral centers in the molecule.
And when you have to chiral centers,
then changing just one doesn't give the mirror image.
It gives an EPA Mer,
not an [inaudible] anti tumor.
So they are die a stereo topic right now for these kinds of problems.
Derek HR Barton invented what was called con formational analysis in 1950 he was
interested in,
in these steroid hormones,
as many people were,
right?
So conventionally these six membered rings were labeled a,
B,
c,
and then the five membered ring d so people could know what they were talking
about,
right?
And Barton redrew ring a and notice that the Beta Alpha is configuration Tully
Daya Steria topic.
You'd have to break bonds to make the alpha in debater.
So it doesn't surprise us that there are different,
right?
But let's look at just how they're different.
So this is the picture from his paper in 1950 that Barton drew to show that ring
a and the bracket there that I've drawn in shows where it would go on to ring
be.
I've truncated his picture.
Now I want to ask you a question about,
so Beta,
uh,
goes up relative to the mean play into the ring.
And Alpha goes down
and he labeled these things,
e or p four equatorial.
That's what we still call it.
As I told you the one that points more or less in the play into the ring and he
called the the others p four polar as if it were a globe and headed the access
the pole,
but we call it now axial.
So that's changed since he invented this.
But I think you're probably sophisticated enough now having had this practice to
recognize an error in what he drew.
Do you see what's wrong with his pictures?
Marty,
what do you say
are the equatorial bonds?
Do they make zs with the carbon frame?
That is,
are they anti to the next adjacent carbon carbon bond take.
Take an Ecuadorian one like this one here is this carbon carbon bond anti
parallel at the correct o clock relative to this bond.
Can't hear very well.
Can you speak more like
no.
This one notices exactly horizontal and this one is exactly horizontal,
so they're perfectly auntie or take this one right.
Here's its bond and here's the next adjacent CC bogged one to 10 and they're
exactly anti parallel.
Okay,
so that's Auntie too.
So the equatorial ones are fine.
How about the axial ones?
They look good.
Catherine,
what do you say?
What does axial mean?
What's axial about it?
Maria.
Okay.
What direction does that access point that you could rotate that six membered
ring around it and get the same thing?
What a clock does it point from the center of the ring?
Yeah.
By about 11 o'clock they're,
there are the,
the sets of three carbons that are related by that and the access goes at about
11 o'clock.
What does that mean,
Maria,
about the,
the axial bonds,
they should be parallel to that axial direction.
Right?
So they really should be this direction,
right.
Parallel to that axis.
So the very guy who invented it in the very paper in which he did the invention
drew them wrong.
That's not too surprising.
Right?
But,
but it's interesting to note.
So you don't have to feel bad when you draw it wrong the first few times.
But the time we get to an exam,
you'll know how to draw it right.
Better than Barton did when he published his paper.
Okay.
He got the Nobel Prize in 1969 for development of the concept of confirmation
and its applications in chemistry.
So he didn't get the Nobel prize for drawing the axial bonds wrong.
Right.
What he got the Nobel prize was for the application showing how important this
was in chemistry,
that those axial and equatorial groups,
hydrogens in this case,
but they could be other groups have different chemistry.
Right?
And notice the date,
1950,
all these things about stereochemistry were happening within plus or minus a few
years of that,
uh,
that we've already talked about by foot.
Determining the absolute configuration of tartaric acid,
Newman,
figuring out how to draw his projections that show confirmation,
the con in gold pray log rules.
And as we'll see shortly the idea of molecular mechanics.
Okay.
Now,
uh,
what made buyers say everything was the same?
Although he didn't know it was that the ring would flip or converting.
Axial and equatorial is we just look,
but can the ring,
if the ring can flip in this one,
they would also interconvert convert axial and equatorial.
But can the ring flip?
That's the question.
So let's think a little bit more about how the ring flip works.
Notice that during the ring flip as in the top left there,
what's axial,
what's equatorial becomes axial.
So you'll look at the top left,
there's an equatorial bond,
and in the right that becomes an act,
an axial bond.
We're actually,
uh,
you'd call it a what?
A flagpole in the boat,
right?
But when you do the other flip of the blue one,
that one that's purple is there,
right?
So the one that was equatorial in the chair on the top left after flip becomes
axial.
And we already saw that here,
that the ones that are equity Loreal become axial.
When you do the double ring flip.
Okay?
Now,
and by the same token,
the ones that are axial become equatorial.
So if you start on the top left with those two green ones,
which are anti to one another axial,
right?
Notice they pointed a little to the right because the access of the of the
cemetery access is not straight up and down right after the first part of the
flip to the boat looks like that.
And the second part of the flip,
they become Ecuadorian and Gauche to one another where they were anti
originally,
right?
So now if you have fused rings,
that is two six membered rings that share a bond as on the bottom there.
Those two green ones can be part of the second ring Gauche to one another as all
the carbons are around the cyclohexane ring in its chair forum.
So there Goshen,
that's fine.
But if you tried to flip it,
those two green ones with respect to the front car,
the front ring would become axial as on the top left.
And if they pointed axial,
you couldn't possibly complete the ring.
Right?
So here's,
here's the,
here are these,
here's two chairs here and here.
Now if I could,
if I could try to flip this one up,
I could flip this one down.
Probably they're down,
right?
So I got it almost into a boat,
but I can't even make it into a boat,
let alone flip the other ring.
And the reason is that is that these two are tying these,
these two while I'm trying to flip this one.
These two are holding this one and we'll let it go.
They can't become axial to one another,
right?
Just because the carbons can't reach.
Okay.
So in,
in what's called Declan means deca hydro 10 hydrogens on naphthalene.
Naphthalene is like benzine except two of them,
right?
So this is Declan or 10 hydrogens on Napoli and this one is called Trans
Jacqueline,
right?
These two hydrogens are trans to one another.
And in that one,
I can't flip the rings.
If I had cysts Declan like this,
right?
Then it's possible to flip the rings,
which I could do like this.
Let's see.
Well,
oh,
I think I did it there.
Yeah,
I did.
Okay,
so you can flip the ring if that cyst,
but not if it's trans.
And the point is that you can't take two Ecuadorian,
take two Ecuadorian things and make them both axial in a ring.
Cause those carbons get too far apart to be bridged by the rest of the ring.
But if there,
if,
if they're Gauche to one another,
then they can be ghosted one another on the other side and it can flip.
It's fun to play.
You know,
we used to require people to buy models.
Now you can do things,
uh,
you know,
with computers that make it,
that's probably not worth your money to buy the models,
but it's still a lot of fun and you'll learn something with your hands.
It's like,
you know,
when people have trouble in elementary school with arithmetic,
the,
the teacher gives them toothpicks to count with and so on.
It's a higher level than that,
but it's the same thing.
You learn a lot with your hands.
So it's fun to play with is in fact,
let me a pass around here.
A simplified models,
uh,
that are a chair.
But you can do this trick of changing one into the other by rotating and feeling
it is fun,
right?
So,
so that you have the opportunity to feel it.
I'll pass these around.
All right.
Okay.
The ring flip is impossible for trans Declan.
And uh,
but so Gosha because Gosha is okay within the second ring of Deckland but not
anti.
Okay.
So,
uh,
and you try with models,
if you're skeptical,
if you want to come up afterwards and fiddle with the Lens,
you're free.
Okay.
Now,
nowadays people much more often encounter these things on a,
on animations.
Uh,
but uh,
this is a nice a webpage that we have permission to use in the course.
I mean,
you could use it on your own anyhow on the net if you wanted to.
Uh,
uh,
but it's a cautionary tale because just because it looks nice and works doesn't
mean it gives the right answers.
So let me show you what I mean.
Okay.
So if you go to this website,
you can click there to get it.
Then it's a nice tutorial about what,
uh,
about Khan formation.
So they show for here here for example,
ethane and if you click play,
let's see,
I think I've got it and have it here.
You can step from one position to the next and see what the shape looks like,
not the FAA and is so Sylvere exciting,
but you can see it go down and up as it goes from a eclipse to to Sagard and you
can click on a point and it'll the model we'll turn to show you what it's like.
I'll give an example of this later and there's the staggered and there's the
eclipse.
That's the barrier that goes across and you'll see that that barrier is 5.2
kilojoules per mole because they use their modern and they use Jewel's.
Whereas American organic chemists tend to use kilocalories,
but anyhow,
if you multiply that by 0.239 you get it in kilocalories is what we've been
talking about.
Which would say that the barrier is one,
two,
four kilocalories per mole.
How big is the barrier in ethane?
Does anybody remember from before thanksgiving?
Dana?
It's three right?
Just because they give a fancy chart with numbers on it.
And just to be kind of,
because it's been calculated by some,
uh,
some quantum mechanical program that they got access to it and could use,
doesn't mean the numbers are going to be right and they're not,
they're off by a factor of more than two,
right?
So don't believe everything you see.
That's maybe the primary lesson that this whole unit tells you.
Okay.
It should be 2.9.
So let the buyer beware and situations like that.
If you don't pay anything for it,
you've probably get about that.
But the pictures are still very nice and the general shape is correct.
So here's the rotation in propane and it says the barrier is five kilocalories
from all.
And you know,
it's something like 3.4,
3.3 instead.
Here's butane.
And again,
you can animate that and see the,
the various staggered confirmations and the fully eclipse doing.
And we know the Gosha is supposed to be 0.9 kilocalories per mole,
which is not what this says.
Uh,
and forget the scale on the left,
the,
uh,
we can use that 0.9 to tell how much of the ghosts there should be at
equilibrium.
And W W let's rehearse this again.
Remember it's 10 to the three fourths delta h in kilocalories.
So if it's,
so three fourths of 0.9 is 0.68.
So it means the ratio of Gauche to Auntie should be one to 4.7 4.7 is 10 to the
0.68.
Okay,
so one to five about,
but it depends on what you're talking about because that Goshen is in fact
chiral.
Let's see.
Uh,
I didn't have it here.
Well,
you can,
you can see,
I can do it with my hands.
Okay.
So here's Auntie.
Okay,
here's Gauche,
right?
But goshes chiral it could also be this,
It could be one hand or the other.
The mirror image.
It's like a propeller of Gauche.
Right?
So when I say Gauche,
what do I mean?
Do I mean Gauche plus or do I mean gauche minus or do I mean both of them taken
together?
Because obviously if I include,
if I,
if I have say Goshen mean both of them,
right.
Then I have to multiply this by two and the ratio is one to 2.4 instead of one
to 4.7 okay,
so there has to be this statistical factor taken into account as well.
When you use a collective name like Gauche.
Okay.
The eclipse is 3.4 kilocalories per mole.
That will tell how fast a anti goes to Gauche.
So the difference in the wells heights tells us how much goes to there is that
the equilibrium and the barrier height tells how fast you go from one to the
other.
So how fast do you go from Auntie to ghost?
Do you remember how to do that?
Anybody remember?
Genu you remember how to do it?
How to find out how fast something is.
If you know how big the barrier is,
you have to go across.
No,
but you'll know it for the final.
Okay.
It's 10 to the 13th per second,
pretty fast.
But then slowed down by that same kind of equilibrium constant.
10 to the minus three.
It's how big the barrier is.
Now,
if the barrier is 3.4,
say it was for say the barriers for,
it's about that 10 to the three fourths of is tend to the third,
right?
So it's slowed down by 10 to the third.
It's 10 to the 13th per second times 10 to the minus third.
Right?
So it's 10 to the 10th per second.
Okay.
There it is.
Oops,
I did it wrong.
Uh,
uh,
there's three for us.
What did I do wrong here?
Pardon me.
That's not the difference.
So
I think I've got a Typo here that can happen.
Okay.
Anyhow,
it should I,
I th I think,
uh,
subject to the thinking while I'm not on my feet,
that this should be about 10 to the 10th per second.
Okay.
Any,
you see the,
uh,
you see how you would use it,
right?
10 to the 13th times.
Whoops.
Oh,
I forgot to plug you.
No,
I did play in.
Oh,
it's okay.
Okay.
So,
uh,
there we go.
Hey.
And the fully eclipse barrier is about 4.4 kilocalories per mole,
but that's hard to access experimentally.
Why?
Because experimentally you try to tell how fast one thing goes to another,
right?
But it's possible to get from Auntie to go,
shh.
Without going over that barrier.
And it's possible to go from Gauche to Auntie without going over that barrier to
go from Gauche to Gauche.
Do you have no notice that 360 degrees is the same as zero degrees,
right?
So you can go from,
this goes to,
this goes by going over that barrier,
right?
So can you measure that rate and see what that barrier is?
No,
because there's an easier way to go.
Instead of going like this to get from one goes to the other,
you just go like this,
right?
So there's an easier way to do it.
So you can't measure the rate and know what that barrier is.
That barrier is more or less irrelevant experimentally.
Okay.
Or here's the ring flip in cyclohexane.
Now let me,
uh,
I'll use this one to animate it to show you how you can try this program
yourself.
Okay?
So here,
here we go.
On there,
there's the thing doing its ring flip.
And it's nice because you can grab it and rotate it around and see it from
different points of view as it does its ring flip.
So there's flipping one end down and then flipping the other end up right to go
from one chair to the other.
So you can fiddle with this or you can get models and try them to,
okay.
Or as I said,
you can go,
we get stopped that and you can go over here and see what it looks like at the,
at the,
uh,
at the halfway point.
Now notice that that is a little bit like a boat,
but it's a twisted boat as I said,
because the actual boat is up here at the top.
In fact,
even at the top,
it's not of an apartment.
I said the wrong thing,
it's not up at the top.
It's sort of a half chair,
half boat,
right?
This,
this top left carbon is still in the sort of chair like form or these five
carbons are,
but this one is halfway bent up toward a boat.
Okay.
Anyhow,
you can fiddle with those things.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
what do I need to do here?
Go back here.
Okay,
so there's the chair Khan from her.
There's the flexible or twisted boat,
Khan from firmer.
Now that one is really fun.
I'm going to do it here.
And people who have this can do it.
Notice,
did you notice when you played with this that the chair is sort of rigid?
If you try to twist it,
it's hard that everybody has everybody's be it felt to feel that.
But if you get into the boat form like that,
then it's quite flexible.
You can do this to your heart's content.
Did you feel that after you've passed it across,
pass it back so everybody can feel how easy is great.
It's like the Orb,
right?
But the,
but the chair is quite rigid,
right?
And as it goes from chair to boat,
it clicks,
like
click,
click.
Okay.
So there's a barrier.
That's the point.
But in the flexible form,
there's not a barrier.
It just smoothly rotates.
Okay.
So there's that barrier of 11 kilocalories per mole.
So it takes some time to get back on forth.
Okay.
And here's the flexible one.
And you can animate that and watch it flex.
Okay,
so that's the twist boat form.
Okay.
Now we're going to talk about the shape,
strain,
energy,
and molecular mechanics.
The point is to talk about molecular mechanics.
How do you get these energies,
that particular animation use the quantum mechanical calculation that didn't do
a very good job on the energies as we just showed.
But is there an easier way to get these energies in that areas?
And it's called molecular mechanics.
Essentially,
it's just using Hooke's law,
uh,
for the model to calculate strain energies.
So we already saw the tortional energy of ethane at three kilocalories per mole,
a threefold barrier,
three minima as you go across,
and the confirmational energy of mutate.
And it's fun to remember those numbers.
Point nine for,
for Auntie to Gauche,
3.4 barrier between them.
And then maybe 4.4 but who knows for the other one?
Okay?
Now remember,
1950 is when all of these things were happening.
So in 1946 there was a paper by Frank Westheimer and Joseph mayor from the
University of Chicago about using mechanics to calculate the energies of
confirmations.
The particular thing they were interested in is when you have to benzene rings,
Hook together so that they can rotate like this,
right?
They can't rotate freely if you have things here that are sticking out that
would run into one another as you try to rotate,
right?
So you could get one that's twisted this way and one that's twisted this way in
a substituted by fennel and you can resolve them and get optically active
forums.
One that's twisted to the right,
one that's twisted to the left,
even though you don't have a carbon that has four different things on it because
it can't rotate,
right?
But the question is how big should that Barry or B and Westheimer was intro
Westheimer in fact,
as you're,
uh,
great uncle,
right?
Cause he also studied with Conant and Kohler at Harvard,
the same as my teacher Bartlett did.
Okay.
So he was interested in physical,
organic chemistry and did this incidentally,
he's also the guy that figured out which hydrogen you pull off on on ethanol,
you know,
that enzyme spent,
uh,
choose between the pro are and the pro se hydrogens.
So Anyhow,
Westheimer did this in 1946 and figured if he,
that the,
if you have a bromine here in a bromine here,
that when it's flat and a Chiral,
that's the transition state between being twisted one way and being twisted.
The other that,
whoops,
sorry,
that these two things would run into one another,
but that would mean the bonds might bend back a little bit or something.
How much energy would that cost?
So he tried to do it by what's called molecular mechanics.
So these programs calculate the energy and they can minimize that by adjusting
angles to get the minimum energy,
uh,
by treating these molecules as if they were mechanical.
And to achieve useful precision.
They require a very large set of empirical force constants.
That is how strong are the various springs.
And you adjust these arbitrarily on some test molecules in order to get the best
values and then try to apply it to something else.
You can also do it nowadays by reliable,
unlike the ones that we just talked about,
quantum mechanical calculations.
But I want to show you how many parameters there are when you do molecular
mechanics.
Okay.
So this is so called m m two.
That's a particular molecular mechanics scheme.
And these are parameters.
So there are 66 different Adam types,
14 different types of carbon depending on what it's bonded to.
Okay.
So here are,
here are some of the,
here are the 14 different types of carbon,
the carbon and the alkane in an alkene in the now kind,
the carbon and the carbon cad I and the carbon and the carbon eel group,
the carbonated carb,
oxalate and so on.
And these have different van der Walls Radii I,
which is one of the things you have to put in.
Okay.
Uh,
now,
then you have these various kinds of Adam's hooked together and you have a
certain strength for stretching the spring.
Oh,
that is to say you need what the you need,
what the equilibrium bond distances,
the minimum energy bond distance and how strong the uh,
forest constant is for stretching that spring.
So notice there are 138 different bond stretching's.
These are just the ones that involve where the first Adam is of type one.
Okay.
So you need to find out what all those forced constants are.
Then you can bend bonds and there are 624 different strengths of springs for
bending different types of bonds.
41 shown here involve alkane carbon,
alkane carbon,
and then some other group.
It could be another alkane carbon.
That's the very top one.
One one one is three Alkane carbons.
So that's the forced constant for bending the bond and,
but then there are different equilibrium bond angles all close to 109 and a
half.
Remember that's the tetrahedral angle,
but a little bit different.
It according to whether that particular carbon has two other our groups on it or
an our group in an age or two H's in addition to the other two groups you're
talking about.
Actually bending the bond.
So you get,
so there are a s so then,
then of course you can twist bonds also.
That's what confirmation involves after all.
And there are 1,494 different bond twisting.
And for each bond twisting you have three parameters here.
For example,
V3 also V to v one for each of those 1500 whatever number it was of bonds.
Now let's show you what that means.
V3 means a threefold barrier and it says its height as 0.0 a nine three
kilocalories per or uh,
yeah,
kilocalories per mole.
So here it is,
right?
It's,
it's maximum when it's a clips,
it's minimum when it staggered,
maximum eclipse minimum staggered.
So that's a threefold barrier for rotating.
But there's also for a particular kind of set of three bonds,
there's a twofold barrier which looks like that,
right?
And that one,
you see his 0.27 kilocalories high and there's also a one fold barrier
like that,
right?
Which is for that particular one,
Al k and l,
K and l,
K and L K and 0.2 kilo calories high.
Now you add all these together and that is the torsional contribution to the
energy and butane or anything where you have car al k,
now,
k,
now l,
k now cane.
Right now we know what it really looks like and butane,
it looks like that the scale is much bigger.
So this is a rather minor contribution.
Now,
why is it that the ante is the most stable according to this scheme?
It's because it's in the Vander walls.
Repulsion is least when these two carbons are as far apart from one another
rather than being eclipsed with one another.
Right?
Uh,
but that then is by it.
You calculate that Vander walls repulsion,
which depends on the radio.
I have various things,
right?
And,
and you then tweak it by adding this to it all,
uh,
as well.
Right?
So you can see that these are pretty complicated for a computer.
It's not a problem.
It's a lot easier than quantum mechanics finding all these curvatures and stuff.
But,
but it's still a pretty intricate thing and an enormous number of parameters.
After simplification,
there's so-called mm,
three scheme has more than 2000 arbitrarily adjustable parameters that you have
to fill out by knowing a lot of different experimental results.
And what would I have to make the numbers to make that right?
And then it has to be also right with this one,
this one,
this one.
So obviously you need at least 2000 different molecules to determine 2000
parameters are 2000 different measurements at least.
So it's a very highly parameterized system.
Contrast that with quantum mechanics where there are no arbitrary parameters.
All you have is the particle masses,
their charges and plunks constant,
right?
So there's nothing fundamentally correct about molecular mechanics.
It's just a very complicated scheme that's been tweaked to try to give good
results for the molecules that it's tweaked on the basis of.
But that doesn't necessarily mean that it'll work for anything else.
Uh,
but it does work pretty well.
And the Nice thing about it is by looking at the calculations,
you can figure out why things happen the way I do with,
for example,
here's ideal cyclohexane and the way that we've been drawing it.
And we can look at the various kinds of strain that there are in that first,
we take an ideal cyclohexane,
which means it has ideal bond lengths,
bond angles,
and is staggered like this.
Okay.
And there's no,
no strain of court for stretch bend or what's called stretch band.
Why is there a term called stretch bend?
Because when you stretch a bond,
it might be easier to bend or conceivably harder to bend when it stretched.
So you have to put another term in for that.
Okay.
But there is tortional energy because they're Gauche interactions here.
Uh,
like that one.
But there are six of them as you go around the ring.
So they're not anti.
So there's tortional energy and then there's what's called non one for van der
walls energy,
which in fact is favorable.
It's attractive.
Okay.
And here you see at example,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
those Adam's Adam one and Adam five,
there are five atoms apart,
right?
So it's non one four,
it's one five.
And they're at a distance where their interaction is attractive according to
Vander walls energy.
But you can have one for Vander walls energy,
uh,
as,
here,
there's one,
two,
three,
four,
and that you see is costs you,
it's it's strain of 6.3 kilocalories per mole.
Not that particular one,
but some of them all up.
Okay?
There's a very bad one here.
You can see between one and eight.
Those are very,
those are rather close together.
Okay?
So there's this much strain in that.
Now what a molecular mechanics program can do is adjust the geometry,
twist bond,
stretch them,
bend them,
and so on to minimize the energy.
Okay?
And here's what happens.
Where's the total strain energy before a diff defamation is almost eight
kilocalories from wall after.
Let's see,
what did I do after you've minimized it?
Those are the energies.
It falls by to 6.5600000000000005.
So he gets a kilo calorie 0.3 better.
Okay.
Now notice what happened.
It stretched the bonds a little bit.
It bent the bonds a little bit,
right?
Let's see exactly what it did by looking at the model.
So there's the,
it's going to stretch and flatten the rings slightly to reduce that bad Vander
walls repulsion.
Notice the van or the one for Vander walls before was 6.32 and it's cut down to
4.68.
So watch what happens.
So this is,
did you see it?
Let's back up.
See it flattens and stretches just the bit to get the reduced those Vander walls
repulsions so that's this.
So this way I told you to draw a cyclohexane to get at the same way more did is
the way organic chemists do it,
but it's not quite right.
Actually.
The rings flatten a little bit and the things that are should be axial spread
out just a little bit.
Okay.
Um,
fine.
So some things get better,
some things get worse.
Overall it gets a little better and it would be very hard to do that in your
head.
Right?
The molecular mechanics is good to do that.
Okay.
Now there you notice is a gauche butane within the cyclohexane and we know how
much gauche butane costs compared to anti butane.
How much strain is there and Gauche butane,
do you remember Gauche versus Auntie?
I said that was worth remembering.
It's 0.9 kilocalories per mole.
Okay.
But in fact,
in the whole,
there are six Gauche butanes cause every bond is part of a Gauche.
Butte is the central bond to negotiate butane.
So if you,
if you ted six Gauche butanes,
that would be a strain of six times 0.9 5.4 kilocalories per mole.
Okay.
And in fact that's rather close to 6.5600000000000005 so that actually is way
over simplified.
So,
but it's a good mnemonic device for remembering how big it is.
It's about six Gauche butanes.
Or suppose you had axial methyl cyclohexane.
Now you have much,
much worse Vander walls interactions,
right?
Six and eight kilocalories per mole of strain.
But what's going to happen if I let it relax,
if I run like a mechanics and let it minimize its energy?
Can you guess what's going to happen?
How will the Structure Change
Virginia?
Yeah.
That methyl group on the top is really in trouble,
right?
Because of those,
those non one for Vander walls repulsion.
But if you bend it back to the right a little bit,
you'll real reduce that.
So here's what happens.
It relaxes like that.
And now notice that the non one for Vander walls went from being bad by six
kilocalories per mole to being good by 1.3 overall.
Some of them all up right?
So it went from 16 kilocalories of strain to only not hire from 17 denied.
Okay?
And notice that here,
there are two more Gauche butanes in the,
in axial methyl cyclohexane.
There were already six in the cyclohexane ring.
Now there are two more.
So you'd guess,
uh,
you'd guess,
whoops,
I went too fast.
You'd guess.
Uh,
uh,
eight times 0.9 7.2.
It's 8.6.
It's in the right ballpark.
So it's roughly what you would expect for eight Gauche butanes.
Okay.
Now if you go from axial to equity Loreal,
then it turns out that energy difference is 1.8 kilocalories per mole equatorial
is 1.8 better than axial?
Does that surprise you?
That is 1.8 could you have guessed that it would be 1.8 notice what it was
axial.
There were two Gauche butane interactions.
Okay.
When it's equatorial,
those two Gauche butanes become anti butanes.
And a Gauche to Auntie is 0.9.
There are two of them.
So 1.8 right?
Two goshes become two aunties.
So that's axial to equatorial.
And in fact,
you could put other groups,
they're like,
instead of a methyl group,
it could be chlorine or bromine or ethyl or something like that.
And for any of these,
if you can measure the amount of aquatory,
equatorial and axial,
you can get a major of how big that group is,
right?
So that these so called a values,
the difference between energy when it's axial on what its equity.
Loreal is a,
a nice rough measure of the group,
effective group size.
Uh,
so we'll stop here for now and continue next time.